One of my jars of coins.
Got To
that wasn't very far.
They've even been on one row.
All right,
well wisdom along that William along this row,
foster cat is just shaken pass.
Now I everybody who is everybody who has had a hose at access to those jars.
Can you please write down on your notebook,
just write down,
but don't judge your neighbor right down for each of those two jobs,
how many coins you think are in the small jar and how many coins you think are
in the large job,
how many Koreans in kind of the small char and how many coins you think are in
the lodge.
All right,
keep passing it along.
so today I want to talk about auctions and just to put this in the context of
the whole class,
way back on the very first day of the class we talked about different types of
people playing games.
We talked about evil gets versus indignant angels.
And then for most of the course,
really until this week,
we've been assuming that you knew who it was you were playing,
you knew your own payoffs,
but you also knew who it was you were playing against or with.
All right?
But the feature that new feature of this week has been that we're looking at
settings where you don't necessarily know what are the payoffs of the other
people involved in the game or strategic situation.
So in the sibling model we looked at last time,
the different types of worker had different types of payoffs from going to,
from going to uh,
uh,
does it get an Mba from going to business school and they yielded different
payoff to you if you hired them.
All right,
let's wait.
And we have to model the game where you didn't quite know the payoff to the
people you were playing against.
And similarly an auction is we're going to study today is such a static.
Typically in an auction you are competing or playing with or against the other
bidders,
but typically you don't know something crucial about those other bidders.
You don't know how much they value the good in question,
right?
Somebody,
there's a good out for sale and you don't know how much they value that.
Good.
So I want to start off by thinking about a little bit of this,
of informational structure of auctions and then we'll get into more detail as we
go along.
And the first thing I wanted to distinguish our two extremes.
One extreme,
I want to talk about common values.
I know the other extreme I want to talk about private values.
So the idea of a common value auction is that the good that is for sale
ultimately has the same value for whoever buys it
all right?
Now that doesn't mean they're all going to be provided to bid the same amount
because they may not know what that value is,
right?
That for example,
imagine there's an oil well,
right answer.
There's an oil one out that there's,
there's,
it doesn't oil reserve out that and different companies are trying to estimate
how much they want to bid for the right to draw oil out of this oil field.
Each of them is going to make it a little practice well and get some estimate of
how much oil there isn't the well,
so they're gonna be different amounts.
But at the end of the day,
what comes out of that?
Well,
it's the same for everybody.
It's the,
that is just one amount of oil in that well and that oil is just worth one
amount,
uh,
at the market price.
All right,
so that's a classic example of a common value auction.
The value,
oh,
the good for sale,
the true value for like,
it's the same for all
and willing to use an invitation v Okay
to do note this common value that this object has.
Now the other extreme is private value and it's really such an extreme.
It's hard to think of good examples,
but the idea is that the value of the good at hand is not only is it different
for everybody,
but my evaluation of this good has no bearing whatsoever on your value for the
good and your value for the good has no bearing whatsoever on my value for them.
All right?
All right,
so here's a case where the value of the good,
the ultimate value of the good in question
no one is it different for all.
Okay,
how many is it different for all?
But moreover it's completely,
it isn't cratic
and my value
is irrelevant
to you.
All right?
So if you,
if you buy,
if you happen to buy this good and you learn that in fact I valued a lot that
makes no difference to how well how happy you feel that having bought the good
right now these are extremes and most of reality lies between or actually give
you a notation.
Let's Use v sub I,
let's Use v Saabye to be the private values.
Were I the notes,
the player in question there.
These are extremes and most things lie in between.
So we already mentioned that on this extreme close to this extreme,
you could think about the oil wells.
All right.
Oil Wells are pretty much common value.
Good.
There's a certain amount of oil there and that's all there is to it.
However,
even there you could imagine that the different firms have different costs on
extracting that oil or these different firms have their machinery occupied to
different extents in other wells that they're digging.
So even in that pure case,
seemingly perfect example of a common value,
it probably isn't literally a common value.
All right?
Or these different firms have different distances between the wells on their
refineries.
All right,
so the oil one is a good example of something that's close to common value,
but it isn't really literally common value probably in reality,
once tempted to say that homes are private value after all my evaluation,
my happiness from living in my house is not really affected by how happy you
would feel living in my house.
Right?
I didn't really care if you would like to live in my house,
so if you wouldn't like to live in my house because I'm the person living in it.
Is that right?
Bots?
There's a catch here.
What's the catch?
Which makes homes not literally private valley.
The catch is that at some point in time,
I may want to resell my hope,
right?
The home is a durable good.
It's,
it's,
it's a consumption.
Good.
My living in it.
That's a private value.
All right,
but it's also an investment.
Good.
I'm going to want to resell that home at some point when I'm kicked out of Yale
or whatever.
All right,
and then at that point,
which I eat salads,
I'm going to care a lot about how much you value is right?
Because that's going to affect the price that I'm going to get at the end of the
day.
So in a,
in the case of a home,
it's somewhere between a private value and a colon.
A value.
Okay?
It's true that the consumption part might be private value,
but the investment component introduced is common values.
All right.
So really for private values,
for pure private values,
we need to think about pure consumption goods.
Goods that I consume,
they have no investment value.
They have no resale value.
So think about some good being sold on Ebay.
It's a cake.
So if I buy it once,
I've eaten it,
I can't resell it,
I can't have my cake.
And we started.
All right.
So think about pure consumption of goods over here.
And even in these pure consumption goods,
I mustn't get any psychological value out of thinking.
I managed to get that cake and you didn't.
All right.
So the private value case is really an extreme thing,
but it turns out to be a useful abstraction when we come to consider things
further.
All right?
Now where's my jars?
Got To?
Am I jealous?
Oh,
plenty.
I said,
okay,
so I can suddenly,
I've got 72 rows I can,
I can play with here.
Let's talk about this auction for the jar.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to have people bid for the,
for the value in the jar.
They're going to get,
they,
they going to put forward a bid.
The highest bidder is gonna win.
And what they're going to win is the amount of money in the jar because they're
going to pay.
Is that bitch?
All right.
So what is that?
Is that a common value or a private value?
That's a common value,
right?
There is a certain amount of money in that jar.
You don't know what it is,
but there is a certain amount of money in that jar and that's the common value.
All right,
so pretty much our jaws of Koreans.
Yeah,
light over here.
That probably even a pure example down the oil.
Well,
all right,
now let me get the first.
Let me get the first two rows of the,
of the class.
So,
uh,
this row here and this row here,
all of you have,
all of you have now had a chance to have a look at the jars.
Let me just get you to write down on without looking at each other at each
other.
Write down on your notepads and you've already written down how many jars do
you,
how many coins you can,
the jar for the,
for the,
uh,
for the large jar.
We'll do the large door first.
Write down your bed.
You can't cheek later on.
All right,
well we're playing this for real cash,
right?
So if you win,
you're going to have to pay me.
All right?
So write down what you're going to be.
Well,
I might not hold it to you if you,
if it's too crazy,
but we'll,
we'll,
we'll see what will,
at least in principle plank for real cash.
All right?
So write down your bit.
Show without changing a bed.
Show your neighbor your bed.
All right.
Alright,
now what I'm going to do is if I can just borrow,
borrow out a second.
Uh,
here's some shock.
Let me,
um,
let me go along the row and find out what those beds were.
[inaudible] want to record the beds.
All right?
So we're gonna record everybody's beatable.
Come back and talk about it afterwards.
Alright,
what are those jars,
by the way?
Let's have a look at the west.
The jog on it.
Who's,
who's got the large jar that hold up the light?
Yeah,
the woman in the corner.
Hold up that large jars.
Everyone can see it.
All right.
That's,
that's the bit,
it's a,
it's a coins in a Sainsbury's Pesto Jar.
Since risk pastor turned out to be quite good.
All right.
Okay.
So I wouldn't bother with names today.
I'm just gonna get your beds.
All right.
Evidence.
Everyone's written down a bait.
No one's gonna cheese.
All right,
so what is your bed?
$4 and 50 cents.
$3 she shouted.
US ever going to hear $3 $4 99 cents.
All right,
I'm going to pass this along.
So
80 cents,
three 80.
That's a shout loud on that.
What was that?
[inaudible] 83 $84 $4 again.
Do dollars and 9 cents.
$2 and 9 cents.
$3
[inaudible] $62 and 1 cent.
Sorry.
The last,
uh,
the last one was what?
What?
We're going to two a water here.
That was after I won 60 though.
That was off throw one 16
all right.
Sorry.
Yep.
89 cents 89 cents just for the big jar.
The big job.
One 41 40 all right.
Are we going a second rows worth of people?
40114150150 $3 $3 $2 $2 four 54 $55 $5 we're getting some high ones now.
1 cent.
Okay.
What's wrong with my job?
All right.
Pass that along.
Second,
crazy.
88 that was an AC.
150150150 $9 a dollar dollar $20 20 and three more.
And dollar 50 a dollar.
$52.
All right,
so you have lots of bids.
And the winner is,
uh,
the last one was $2.
I've actually forgotten how many coins were in here.
Let me just remind myself.
This was the large jar,
right?
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
I know again,
okay.
All right.
So who is all winner that,
uh,
I've got a four 50 a five.
There's a fine.
Okay,
so here's,
here's our winner.
Who's our winner.
Okay,
so let's,
that's how have a to stand up a second.
All right,
so now a round of applause for our window,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
No,
let's talk about how people Baden,
why they paid that amount,
that amount.
Okay.
So let's start with all winner.
Alright,
let's start with our winner.
All right.
So why don't you bid $5?
It looked like there could be about $5.
So I've gotten your name.
My name is Ashley.
So Ashley is saying she bayed roughly $5 cause it looked like there was about $5
in there.
Plus she gets the jar.
Plus you get the jaw.
I,
yeah,
I'm not sure.
I'm throwing it in the jar.
Okay.
All right.
So let's,
let's solve a few other people and see what they say.
What did you say again?
I said a buck 60 because,
um,
I didn't want to over a estimated because then I'd have to pay you more than I'd
get.
All right,
so,
so what was your,
what was your estimate?
My estimate was about one 80 to 200.
All right.
So your estimate was one 80 to 200 and you bet around one 60 a person next to
you?
Um,
well I guess three and same reasoning.
I,
I thought they would probably be about $4 and then I asked,
I valued at like $1.
All right,
so,
so you,
you thought there's about $4 worth of coin,
then you actually bid three.
Three.
All right,
so all of you actually wrote down initially how many coins you thought were in
there,
right?
Is that right?
Let's just get some idea of the distribution of those.
So how many people thought there was less than a dollar in there?
What brings out the no shame here?
Just raise your hands.
How many people thought that was between a dollar and a dollar?
50.
How many of you thought it was a dollar between a dollar 50 and $2?
Some might be on the back of your hand.
Okay.
How many people thought it was between $2 and $2 50 [inaudible] older between
two to $2 50 and $3 right?
How about,
how about more than three 50
alright,
I'll clear the people who bit hired hit.
Okay,
so we have a whole of estimates there and wide range of estimates,
a wide range of beds and people are saying things like,
wow,
I thought my baby was,
I thought it was this many coins in there.
Maybe I shaded down a little bit from the number of coins I thought was in there
because I want to make some profit on this.
Is that right?
That's kind of the,
that's kind of the explanations I'm hearing from people.
All right.
And Oh,
what I want you to suggest is that not a very good way to bid in this auction.
Right?
All right.
Just repeat what I think people date and people can contradict me if this is
wrong.
I think most people,
they look to the,
there,
they shook this thing,
they waited a bit,
they figured out there was let's say three 50 worth of pennies in that.
And then they said,
okay,
three 50 so I'll bid,
I don't know,
three to 43 30 isn't like that.
All right,
so what's wrong with that?
What's wrong with that?
All right,
well,
first of all to reveal it,
so something wrong with it.
Let me tell you how many Koreans were in there now in the larger jar there where
it was $2 and 7 cents.
$2 and 7 cents.
How many of you paid more than $2 and 7 cents [inaudible] raise your hands.
All right.
Quite a few of you.
All right,
so what we see here is a number of people including our winner bid a lot more
than that.
Then the number of coins and the job.
All right.
What we find is by a lot is that the winning bid
was much,
much greater than the true value,
and this is a common phenomenon in common value auctions.
It's such a common,
but it's such a common phenomenon that it has a name.
The name is the winner's curse.
It's the winner's curse
and the main lesson of the first half of the day is going to be,
let's figure out why there is exist to winner's curse.
Let's try and avoid falling into a winner's curse.
And maybe that's even forgot how to do better.
All right,
so let's try and think through why it is we fall into a winner's curse.
All right?
So one way to think about this is to think about naive bidding in this context.
So I suppose what people suppose people's strategy,
suppose people's strategy was actually to bid their estimate.
I know that isn't what people did.
Most people shade to the rest of it,
a little base,
but most people get pretty close to their estimate.
All right?
What's going to happen in that instance is what people are going to bid
essentially what they,
what they think it's worth.
And we just saw that fully,
uh,
fully were half of you.
I think half of the people like we,
we sampled overestimated the number of coins in there.
That right?
We just have that show of hands.
How many people raise your hands again,
just be honest.
If you,
if you thought it was more than two oh seven in that as maybe maybe roughly a
half,
roughly,
maybe a little bit less than a half of you overestimated the number of coins in
there.
Now?
What's that?
What's that going to mean?
It's going to mean all of those people who have this overestimates are going to
overbid.
All right?
But we can be a little bit more general and a little bit more rigorous about
this.
So let's try and be a little bit more general.
All right,
so first of all,
let's just make sure we understand what the payoffs are.
This auction,
the payoff in this auction
is what
you get the true value.
You get the number of of of Koans,
a number of pennies in the jar,
minus your bed
if you are the highest
and you get zero.
Otherwise,
hi around.
Just I think it's straight forward.
We all understand that's what the value is and what do people do?
People try to estimate this is,
this is not a mistake.
People tried to estimate how many coins were in the jaw.
Now,
in fact,
the true number of coins on the jaw was V,
which turned out to be two,
207 all right?
But when people estimate is they don't get it exactly right.
Neither here where you're shaking the jar,
nor in the case of these oil samples.
All right,
so what they actually estimates each person forms an estimate,
which we could.
Cool.
Why I and this why we could think of as being the truth plus noise.
So it's quite Absalon I that's even been a tiller of art.
Make it clear.
It's kind of a random cell.
All right,
so for some people epsilon I is a,
it's going to be a positive amounts,
which means they're gonna own our estimates.
The value or the number of coins in the jar,
and for some people apps on is going to be a negative amount,
which means they're gonna underestimate the number of codons in the job.
All right?
Everyone agree with that?
That doesn't,
that's not a controversial statement,
right?
Does that ever okay with that?
All right,
so let's think about the distribution of these wise.
Let's draw a picture
that has on the horizontal access all the different estimates that people could
form of the number of coins on the jar.
And let's anchor this by v.
So here's V and here is going to be the,
if you like,
the probability of getting that estimate.
All right,
so the number,
the frequency or probability of estimating,
why I given that fee I,
is that all right,
so I don't know what the shape of this distribution is,
but my guess is it's kind of bell shaped,
is that right?
So it's probably,
it probably looks something like this.
Right?
Let me that.
That's implausible.
All right.
And we can actually test this and we had time,
we could actually go round all of you and get you to report what their estimates
were and we could plot that distribution and Steve,
it is bell shape,
but I,
my guess is it's reasonable to assume it's spelled shapes,
right?
There's some central tendency to estimate.
There's something close to the truth.
If I draw on this correctly,
I'd have its highest point at v.
I haven't quite done it correctly.
All right.
I'd say it's probably,
it's probably roughly symmetric.
Okay.
So now suppose that people's bidding strategy is pretty much what they reported.
People are going to bid roughly the estimates of the number of coins and the
jar.
It's suppose people bid.
Okay?
People bid bi roughly equal
to why I,
so I know people are going to shade a little bit,
but let's ignore that for now.
All want to be able to fit in roughly equal to y.
All right,
so what's going to happen here?
All right.
Who's gonna?
Who's gonna win?
Wait,
if people bet,
if this is the way in which the yr is emerge naturally in life,
right?
There's a v as a true vi and then people make some estimate of it,
which is essentially via v plus noise.
Who's going to end up being the winner?
The winner of the,
of the auction.
It's going to be the person who has the highest estimates,
right answers.
It's really a lot of people.
The winner isn't going to be the person who estimated correctly at v.
The winner's going to be way out here somewhere,
right?
The wind is going to be
way up in the right hand tail.
Why?
Because the winner,
the winner,
we'll will then be
the eye.
Who's why I,
it's the biggest is the maximum.
And the problem with this is the person who is white is the biggest,
has what they have the biggest era,
right?
The person who's why I as the Max,
hi e epsilon,
I
is the Max.
And that's exactly what happened when we did estimates just now.
The person who won was the person who who,
uh,
I Ashley,
who had estimated to be roughly maybe a little bit more than $5 worth of coins
in there.
So I'm guessing yes,
that's right.
That no one else estimated more than $5 and these two roads,
is that correct?
No one estimated more than $5.
So the person who the highest estimate bid the most,
which is pretty close to her estimates and that caused her to lose money.
Right.
He ends up owing me a whatever it is,
one 91 93,
which I will collect it afterwards.
All right.
So the winner's curse is caused by this.
It's caused by if people bid taking into account that own estimate and only that
own estimates of the number of coins and the jar or the amount of oil in the
oil,
well then the winner ended up being the person with the highest estimates,
which means the person with the highest era.
All right?
So No cess what this leads to it on average,
on average,
the bid,
the winning bid,
and he's going to be much,
much bigger than the truth
is that right?
Biggest era.
It's typically going to be way out in this right tail,
and that's going to be,
people are going to lose money.
All right?
So this phenomenon is very general because common value auctions are very
general.
I already mentioned the oil fields in the early period after World War II when
the u s government's,
I did auctioning out the rights to drill oil in the Gulf.
All right?
So,
uh,
and the,
and the Gulf of Mexico,
uh,
early on it was observed that these companies are the winning companies or
companies who won the bid each time was losing money.
It was great for the governments.
But these companies,
companies,
we're consistently losing money.
They're consistently overbidding be careful.
It wasn't that the companies as a whole over bidding,
it was that the winning bid was overbidding.
It was the witness curse.
Over time.
Companies figured this out and they figured out that they shouldn't bet as much
and this effect went away.
But you also see this affects in other places where naive bidders are involved.
So for example,
if those people who have been following the baseball free Asian markets,
I think you could argue,
but if someone can do empirical test of this,
you can argue that the winning bids on free agents in the baseball for Asian
market end up being horrible over beads.
But at the same reason,
right?
The team who has the highest idiosyncratic estimates of the person's value ends
up hiring that player.
But the highest it is in credit value tends to be too high.
Right?
And similarly,
perhaps more importantly,
if you look at IPO,
initial public offerings of companies,
they tend to sell to high.
There's very calm,
this one,
baseball,
why don't I haven't got the data?
But the IPA is,
we know that IPO and uh,
there's a tendency for IPOs initial about product offerings of companies to have
too high a share price.
And then for those shares to fall back after a while,
let me be a little bit of initial enthusiasm,
but then they fall back and why?
Again,
the people with the highest estimates of the value of the company end up winning
the company.
And if they're not sophisticated about the,
they bid about the way they bid,
then they overbid.
All right.
So this is a serious problem out there and it raises the problem.
Everybody's,
if the issue,
well,
how should I correct this?
I might it in life,
be involved in an ocean as a bitter for something that has a common value
elements.
How should I think about how I should be?
We've learned that we shouldn't be,
we shouldn't just bait my estimate minus a little.
Alright,
so how should we think about it?
Okay.
Not a Walker's towards that.
Let me try and think about a little bit more about the information that's out
there.
Let's go back to our oil.
Well example,
each of these oil companies drill as a test well in the oil fields and from this
test.
Well each of them get some estimates of why I do.
You can imagine someone doing a test,
a test drill into my jar of coins.
And when they do this test drawn at this jar,
this jar of coins,
they form an estimate.
Why?
I suppose that your estimates of the number of coins in the,
in the jar,
either not of oil in the,
in the oil.
Well suppose that this,
your particular one is equal to 150
all right.
Does it,
and if I,
if I then asked you the question not to not to bid,
but I asked you the question,
how many coins do you think are the jaw?
Your answer would be 150 all right,
there'll be over at your best estimate.
But suppose I then told you that your neighbor,
let's go back to Ashley again.
So Ashley's estimate was was,
let's say it was 150 it wasn't,
but it has 150 and suppose I went to her,
to her neighbor and her and asked her neighbor and her neighbor said,
actually I think there's only 130 in that.
So I suppose Ashley now knows that she did a little test.
She thinks there's 150 but she now knows that her neighbor has done a similar
test and he thinks there's only 130
yeah.
Now what should it be?
Ashley's estimates of the number of coins and the job or somewhere in between,
right?
So probably probably somewhere between 150 and 130 maybe about 140 but certainly
lower than 150 is that right?
That right.
So if I told you that someone else had an estimate that was 20 lower than yours,
that would cause you to lower your belief about how many coins was in the jar.
All right,
now let's push this a little harder.
Suppose I told you,
not that your neighbor had a hundred had an estimate of 130 but just that your
neighbor hadn't estimates that was lower than 150 I'm not going to tell you that
you're what?
I'm not going to tell you exactly what your neighbor estimates.
I'm just going to tell you that his estimate is lower than yours.
All right,
so your initial belief was there was 150 coins in this jar,
but now I know that my neighbor thinks there's fewer than 150 do you think you
estimate is your belief is still 150 or is it lower?
Who?
Who thinks it's gone up hasn't got out?
Right?
Who thinks it's gone down?
It's gone down,
right?
It's going down.
I didn't know exactly by how much to pull it down.
All right,
but the fact that I knew that my neighbor has a lower estimate than me suggest I
should put that suggest that I should have a lower estimate than one 50 now.
So it was actually something more dramatic.
Suppose I go to Ashley and say,
your initial estimates was actually it wasn't 150 it was $5 wasn't it?
That's right.
So your initial estimate was 500 pairs,
right?
And I'm not going to tell you what your neighbor's estimate was.
I'm not going to tell you what your neighbor's neighbor's estimate was,
but I'm going to tell you that every single person in the row in the two rows,
rather than you had an estimate lower than $5 I sorry,
Ashley's,
that's what it was.
$5 but I'm not going to tell her that every single person in the room had a
lower estimate than she,
than hers.
All right?
Try not to tell her it is.
Yeah,
but why you,
Jay is less than why I
fuck Ooh for all Jay,
for all the other people.
All right.
Can I claim that if you tell me that everybody else to a party with 30 other
people there has an estimate lower than mine.
Everyone else watch it.
What should I now estimate?
What?
What should happen to my estimate?
It's going to come down a lot,
right?
It's gonna come down a lot.
Is that right?
I have,
my estimate was $5 but I know everybody else will just one person,
but everybody else had lower estimates.
There might,
my guess,
or the number of coins on the jaw has come down a whole lot
about what,
but that's exactly what Ashley knows.
As soon as she founds out that she's won the auction,
why?
If people are bidding their values,
if people are bidding as,
sorry,
don't about us.
If people are bidding the estimates,
then as soon as Ashley discover she's,
she's one,
she's going to say,
oh,
Boba,
right?
I now know that my estimate was too high to make something more extravagant than
boulder.
Right?
But at the very least might say,
oh,
bother.
I now know that everyone else had a lower estimate than me,
or therefore my estimate of $5 is too high.
All right.
So what's going to happen is if people start bidding,
their estimates are close to their estimates.
Then once they've won,
they're going to learn exactly this.
They're going to learn that everyone else's estimate was lower than theirs and
they're going to regret their choices.
Yeah,
it can't be a good idea.
I called an equilibrium for people to make choices,
which they're going to regret if they win or that's crazy.
All right,
so we need to think about how to correct for that.
so how do we correct for it not?
Let's talk about this a little bit harder.
Each of you,
when you're bidding for this jar of coins,
you,
I claim you only really care about how many coins were in the jar in one
circumstance.
What's the only circumstance in which you care at all?
How many coins are in the job
if you win,
right?
It's I claim,
yeah,
only care.
How many clients
in the jaw?
Well,
how much oil is in the,
well,
if you win,
if your bid is the winning bid and if your bid is the winning bid,
what do you know?
You knew,
you know that your estimates was the highest estimate in the room.
At least.
At least if the secret of master property that beds are increasing and estimates
per say,
which is not much trickled specs.
So you know
in this case
you
would have an estimate why I that was at least as big as why Jay for all,
for all the other people in the room.
All right,
so where are we?
You only care how many coins are in the jar.
If you win and if you win,
you know your estimate was the highest.
So what's the relevant estimates,
the relevant estimate of the number of claims in the jar for you when you're
bidding.
The relevant estimate is not how many coins do I think in this is in this job.
That's the naive thing.
The relevant estimate is how many coins do I think is in this jar given my
shaking events and given the facts that I have won the auction,
we'll give him this opposition that I might win the auction.
All right,
so the relevant estimates in bidding.
Okay.
The relevant estimates
when bidding
is
how many coins
do I think of that
given
my initial guests?
Why Ai and
given,
but why I is bigger than Yj?
Okay.
I know this is the kind of a weird thing.
It's a counter factually.
I don't know what the timing of which I'm bidding.
I don't know that I'm going to win,
right?
But nevertheless,
I should bid as if I knew I was going to win because I don't need care.
And the second time,
which I went,
right.
So the way in which I should estimate the number of the number of coins in the
jaw,
and indeed the way in which I should bid is I should bid the number of coins.
I would think we're in the jar if I want.
Say it again.
I should bid the number of coins.
I would think we're in the jaw if my bit ended up being the winning bed.
Alright,
so the lesson here is
bid as if
you know
you win.
All right?
Betas.
If you know you win.
And why is that a good idea?
Let's go back to this case of now you discover you've one provided you bid as if
you know you won.
When you win,
you're not gonna be disappointed because you already took that information into
account.
Right?
But if you bid not as if you won,
you failed to take a minute to take into account the possibility of winning,
then winnings going to come as a shock to you and cause regret.
I have to,
the only way to prevent this ex post regret wait a bit optimally is to bid as if
you know you're going to win.
Estimate the number of coins,
not on your own sample,
but on the belief that your sample is the biggest song.
Yeah,
there's a question.
I don't really understand what the differences between fitting,
sorry,
I don't,
I don't understand what the differences between bidding as if you know,
you win and what if you want,
right?
Because if you bid,
like whenever you bid,
you're bidding the number that you think,
oh well I think there are this many coins in the jar.
So if I,
when I'm,
I don't want to bid too many so that I don't lose.
Right.
So good.
How is that different from bidding is if you know you win.
This is good.
Okay.
Okay,
good,
good.
So how,
good question.
So how is it different to say bidding as if I know I win.
So it's,
it's bidding.
Okay,
so,
so let me try that again.
So what do,
what are you going to do is you're going to think of the following thought
experiment.
Suppose you told me I won.
Suppose you told me I want it.
Now how many coins do I think are in the jar?
Right?
Let me bid that amount.
All right.
So before we even do the Beta,
through the following thought experiment,
you'll find out how many coins do you think of that?
Now I say,
suppose it turns out that your estimates,
the highest estimates.
Now how many claims do you think of that?
That's what you should bet,
right?
And I'm arguing that that being,
that your estimates,
the highest he's going to drag down.
That dragged down the estimate a long way.
All right.
But the key idea here is if you bid is if you know you win,
then you won't regret winning,
right?
And that's what you want to avoid.
You want to avoid the winner's curse.
All right,
now let's see how that goes on us.
Let me swap places with Allie again and let's see if we can actually very
quickly just do one row on the second job.
All right.
Uh,
so this is the yellow mic.
Alright,
so same,
same group of people,
same group of people are,
let me get to shout these out fairly quick.
Here's what we get.
We move onto this,
these two rows right down in your bed on the smaller jar.
Now on the smaller job,
all right,
this is your bid,
not your estimated,
right?
And you're right on your,
your,
your essence,
your bid on the smaller jar.
All right,
fast as we can go.
just shout out a number.
40 cents,
40 cents.
$1,
$1 2151 58 cents 98 cents $1 90 cents 90 cents 75 cents.
616151514140.
Uh,
okay.
I got to pass this end,
so I'll go get the other side.
Keeps shouting them out.
95 cents.
Haley,
50 50 70 51251205150 bucks.
30 bucks.
31 2120 (509) 100-9115 one 15 and 80.
I think they get everybody.
All right.
80 was the last one.
All right,
so I'll get the bids came down partly because the Jarvis smaller of course,
which is cheesing fast.
Let me just tell you.
Let's find out who the winner was.
First of all.
So one 60 is the winner.
Uh,
one six is the winner and it turns out that the number of clients in this jar
was
one 48.
All right,
so what happened here?
I think people took into account,
people did lower that bids below the estrogen.
Is that,
let's just check actually.
So who is,
who is my one 60 person?
Alright.
Sustenance.
Stand on my one 60 person.
All right.
So how many coins did you think were in that one?
61 60 okay,
I see.
So,
so your name is Robert.
So Robert thought that was what you paid one 60?
Yes.
All right.
How many coins do you think was in there?
One 61 60.
I'm not doing well here.
Am I?
Okay.
All right.
What?
Okay.
Okay,
fine.
Okay.
So what am I trying to convince you to do here?
I try to convince you to do.
All right,
so let,
let me,
let me find some other bidders.
So,
so,
uh,
yes.
So what did you paid?
$1.
How many coins do you think were in there?
One 25.
Okay.
So how many of you be honest now,
how many of you bid significantly below or significantly below your,
your,
uh,
your estimates?
All right,
so the idea,
okay,
raise your hands.
Have you been,
have you ever been bit brother?
You estimate?
All right,
good.
So we're learning something.
I feel like this is the 24th lecture I'm about to teach you something,
right?
Right,
right.
Okay.
So the idea here is in a common value auction,
you need to shade your bed considerably,
right?
In fact,
most of these beds,
even though you are shading your paid considerably,
uh,
most of you didn't shade it enough.
I say even even taking this into account,
even taking into account the lesson of the day,
even with that endo count,
a number of you are still overbidding.
Alright,
so what's the takeaway lesson?
If you're in a common value auction,
a common value auction,
you need to bid as if you had been told that your estimates is the highest
estimates.
That means you need to shave.
Your estimate are locks.
If you don't do this,
you'll win a lot of auctions and you'll be very unhappy.
All right?
All right.
Now we're not done here yet.
Let me move forward by moving away.
Now,
just from common value auctions.
So Steve,
all we focused on common value auctions and we focused on particular structure
of auction.
But I also want to talk about different types of ocean themselves because one
phenomenon you're seeing out there a lot these days is
the people rum,
different structures of auctions and auctions are getting more and more
important than theU s economy.
It used to be the auctions where something you thought of as a pretty rare event
and you'd go or you see them when people are selling capital and you see them
when people was selling art.
But that was pretty much it.
But now you see auctions everywhere.
We see auctioned on Ebay,
we see auctions for the spectrum.
Pretty much everything is auction these days.
So all kinds of becoming important.
In fact,
at Yale this year we had a cost solely devoted to auctions.
We're having one day of this past for 12 months,
but they had a whole 24 lectures on oceans.
All right?
It's not important.
All right.
And one thing we should realize is that there are lots of different types of
auctions.
So let's talk about four different types of auction.
Let's call them a,
B,
c,
and d.
All right?
So the first type of auction is a first price sealed bid auction.
And that's what we just did.
Everybody wrote down their bed on a piece of paper,
all right?
And the winner,
the winner was the person with the highest bid and they paid their bed.
All right,
Ashley,
in the first case,
Jonathan [inaudible],
Jonathan,
and the in the,
in the second Robert on the second one.
All right,
so first price sealed bid auction is what we just did.
And that's a typical auction you to see.
For example,
in house sales,
here's another type of auction though,
so this sounds crazy,
but me write it up anyway.
You could imagine a second price sealed paid ocean.
So what happens in a second?
Price seal,
but ocean,
everybody writes down that bed.
Each per player writes down their bed,
the highest bidder get the good.
It's much the same as before,
but now instead of paying the bed that they wrote down,
they bayed the SA,
they pay the second highest paid,
all right?
It's the idea is the winner.
The winner pays
the second bid.
The winner is the person with the highest bid.
But they pay the second bed.
So that seems crazy,
doesn't it?
Seems a bit crazy.
These are sometimes called Vickery auctions.
Okay.
And Vickery won the Nobel prize so they can't be that crazy.
I will come back and talk about it.
Alright,
here's two other kinds of auction we can think about an ascending open ocean.
Yeah.
So this is what you all think of when we say auction.
This is what happens with a catalog option or an auto auction.
And when people are shouting out beds,
one way to think about this is that we will be,
if we weren't bidding something,
if we were auctioning off something in the class today,
is that everybody who is still in the auction would raise their hands and as the
bid got higher and higher,
some of you would start dropping out.
Is that right?
And eventually when there's only one hand left,
that person would be when the auction is that right?
If that's another version of an ascending open or everybody raises their hand
when the price is zero,
there's the price goes up.
Hands go down until there's only one hand left.
But we can also imagine another crazy origin,
which is a descending open ocean.
So how does the descending,
okay,
open auction,
if I should just say this is the kind of this open extending one is what you
typically see on Ebay.
All right.
What did extending open auction,
I just sending open auction is the same idea almost,
except instead of starting the prices at zero and going up,
I'll start the price at infinity and go down.
All right,
so now if I start at the price in Finnessey,
none of you have your hands up,
I hope.
All right.
And then as the price goes down,
eventually one of you is going to raise that hands and then you,
you get that good and pay that amount.
All right?
So there's auction happens in the real world.
It used to happen in a place called filings basement.
When I was in graduate students,
uh,
struggling to have enough money,
there was a place in Boston called fighting's basement,
which would sell clothing in this way.
So you'd go and pick out the suits you needed for your horrible job interview
and you just [inaudible] the price would come down each week and you'd hope that
no one bought it before you did.
All right.
Sometimes it's called a Dutch auction,
right?
So here's four kinds of auctions.
Two of them seem pretty familiar,
right?
If a and c sound like familiar kind of auctions that you're used to seeing and
BMD seem a little weird.
So the first thing I want to convince you of is that B and d and knowledge,
weird as they seem.
All right,
so let's look at these crazy auctions.
The first thing I want to claim is,
is that auction d
is really the same
as auction a,
just remind us of what let's do.
Auctions are auction a is every,
it's exactly what can we just do it for the coins?
Everybody writes down their bid,
we open all the envelopes and the winter is the hype person with the highest,
highest bid written down or they pay that,
right?
The descending open auction.
Nobody beads,
nobody bids,
nobody reads,
nobody been suddenly suddenly bit some somebody bids and then they pay that
amount.
Why are those two auctions at the same?
Wow.
Think about that descending bid that the offending open auction during that
descending open auction,
each of you may have written down in your head,
it's useful.
Think of it this way,
you've written down in your head the number at which you're going to raise your
hand.
Is that right?
So there are now as a graduate student waiting for my suit to come down in price
so I can afford it and I know what that number is.
And then from your point of view,
the other potential wearers of the suits,
all right,
from your point of view,
that's a seal bid for me,
right?
At the end of the day,
whoever has that highest intended bid,
that highest seal bid will end up winning the suit and they'll pay that bit,
right?
So from a strategic point of view,
the descending open auction and the sea,
the descending open auction and the seals first price auction are the same
thing.
The person who has the highest bid,
the highest strategy wins and they pay their bed and you don't get it.
You don't get to see animals and strategy until it's too late.
All right,
so d is equal to to a what about B and d?
Okay,
so I claim that B and d are not the same,
but they're very closely related.
Sorry,
B and c.
C,
so c is what see is our Ebay auctions are classic auction.
You're all used to playing on Ebay and B,
B is this slightly crazy thing where we all write down beds and the winner is
the person who has the highest bid but they only pay the second amount.
How?
Why?
Why am I saying that's the same as our Ebay auction in some ways?
Well,
let's think about the Ebay auction.
He you all playing the Ebay auction,
so all of you have your hands up,
meaning you're still in and the price is going up,
prices are going up over time and all of you that have your hands up,
you're still in it,
right?
Each of you has some strategy in mind,
which is what the strategy is.
When am I going to lower my hand?
Right?
What's the highest price I'm willing to pay,
high price price,
I'm going to pay for this object.
So your strategy in the classic Ebay auction is the price at which I love on my
hand.
All right.
Who Wins in that open ascending auction?
The person who has the highest intended bid,
the person whose hand is up at the end is the person who's who's intended bid is
the highest,
but what amount do they pay?
When does the ocean stop under the ocean stuff?
It stops when the second to last hand goes down,
right?
So if my,
if,
if I'm the winning bid in an o and an openness sending ocean,
my hand is still up.
You don't know what I was willing to pay.
What I'm actually going to pay is the price of the last person whose hand went
down.
I ain't going to pay the bid of the person who's,
who's,
who's amount they're going to pay is the second highest amount.
That makes sense.
So in an ascending open ocean,
the winner,
the person who has the highest intended bid,
actually pays the amount,
the intended,
highest intended bid off the second highest player.
All right,
so an ascending oak and ocean.
It's structurally very similar to the seal,
but oceans,
which is really why the sealed bid auctions are interesting.
The second price deal,
but it was awkward.
Interesting.
Now,
having said that,
they're not like they're not exactly the same,
and the reason they are not exactly the same is that if in fact the good for
sale has common value than we might learn something by the fact that the hands
are up.
All right?
So the fact that people's hands are still up in the open auction,
whereas you can't see what people are doing in the sealed auction makes these
not identical,
but there's clearly a close similarity between them.
All right?
Now let's us,
I guess the question people even up you've been wondering about,
which is how should I bid at Ebay?
We figured out that for colon value auction,
if you're going to reset coming color,
the auction on Ebay,
for example,
if the good you're buying is a good year,
you're later on.
I'm going to want to resell.
In that case,
we already know that you should,
should should shade shade your estimate of the value considerably.
So let's go to the other extreme.
Let's consider a private valley
a private value.
Well,
there's no common value here at all.
And let's assume that this auction,
he's either second price sealed bid.
Oh,
open or sanding.
There's summarize.
It's either what we call B or what we call sync.
All right,
so you're,
there you are.
You're bidding on Ebay and it's a private value.
Good.
There's nothing interesting about how much anyone else values this thing.
All right,
so what's your value?
Your value is VI,
right?
You might bid bi tool.
This is your value.
Your bid is bi,
and what's your payoff
you'll pay off is
vi minor is no minus bi.
What's it minus?
It's going to be minus,
let's call it be jade bod.
I'll say what is the minutes?
So you'll value your payoff is the value of the goods to you.
Minus this thing.
I'm going to call Bj Bar,
which say what?
It isn't the minutes if you went.
So if ba is is,
is highest
and it's zero,
otherwise is that right?
So what Bj Bar Bj Bar is
the highest.
I'll bet,
right?
So if my bid is the highest,
my final payoff is the value of the good to me minus the highest other bit.
The second highest paid in other words,
all right,
so question,
how should I be on?
How should I be either on Ebay here or for that matter in a,
in a second price deal,
bid auction?
What's the right way to bid in these auctions?
Should I bid my value?
Should I be under my value?
As of a poll?
Who thinks you should?
Who thinks should have been over your [inaudible]?
Are you going to pay the second price?
So who thinks she's should pay over your value?
Who needs you a bit over your value?
Who thinks she's a bit of your value?
He think should have been under your value.
All right.
Everyone knows this.
That's good.
Okay,
good,
good.
That's that's correct.
So the optimal thing to do is bid
your
valley video value.
I actually,
we can do better than that.
We can show,
we haven't got time now,
but we can show that bidding your value in a second price option is a weekly
dominant strategy,
right?
So setting
be,
hi,
equal to VI is weekly
dominant.
It's a weekly dominant strategy.
It's really a very good idea.
Alright,
so there's nothing subtle about bidding on Ebay.
If truly a private value auction,
you're going to spin until it hits your value and then you got to drop out.
Right?
Okay,
Holly proving that as an exercise.
What about if we,
if we switch from the second price auction or Ebay to a first price auction?
Okay,
so now your payoff is v I minus your own bed.
If you win and zero all the lies.
Why should a first price auction,
you're going to get your value minus your own bed if you win and zero otherwise,
now,
how should you be?
This is a private value auctions.
You don't have to worry anymore about the winner's curse,
but nevertheless,
how should you be?
Should you paid more than your value?
Should you bid the same as your value or should you bid less than your valley
who they should have been more than your value to the poll?
Who thinks you should build your value?
Who thinks he's a bit less than your value?
Yeah,
the alters you here,
you should bid less than your value.
That.
See,
why
bid less than vi?
Why?
Because if you bid vie,
even if you win the auction,
what's going to be your payoff?
Zero.
If you lose the oxygen getting through,
if you win the auction,
you get zero.
If you bid less than via,
if you shaved your database,
then if you win,
which will happen with some pro bowlesy,
you'll make some,
you'll make some surplus.
All right,
so here it's flipped around here.
It turns out
that building your value
and the first price auction is weekly dominated.
Yeah.
All right.
Where all,
we haven't got much time.
I want to get one more thing out of the class.
So where are we here?
What we've argued is in a first,
in a second price auction,
you're going to beat your value,
but yet,
but the wind is only going to pay the second price in a first price auction,
you're going to shade your bed under your value,
you're going to trade off two things.
The two things you're going to trade off are the,
as you raise your bed,
you'll increase your chance of winning the auction,
but you'll get less surplus if you win.
All right,
so the first price auction is a classic trade off marginal benefit and marginal
cost.
The marginal benefit of raising your bait as you increase the probability of
winning,
the marginal cost is you'll get less surplus if you went all right,
but in summary,
in the second price auction,
I bid my,
I'd bid quote truthfully my value,
but if I went only I only pay the second price in the first price auction,
I bid less than my value,
but I pay what I paid.
If I win,
I'm at leads us to the natural question.
Which of these two auctions at least an expectation is going to raise more
money?
Let me make some assumptions.
Let's assume that it's a purely private value environment and let's assume that
these,
let's also assume that these values are completely independent,
but my value is this statistically completely independent in your value.
They're just completely idiosyncratic.
And let's assume that we're all kind of basically similar except for that.
All right,
so I'm going to steam independence,
cemetery,
private values.
Most importantly you can imagine.
Let's ask the question again.
I'm,
I am selling the good.
Now would I rather sell this as a second price auction in which at least he'll
be your values,
but the winner will only pay the second battery or would I rather?
But as I started as a first price auction in which you're all going to shade
your values because of this,
uh,
this,
this effect of,
of,
uh,
of trying to get some surplus,
but at least the winner will actually pay you what they bet,
which is going to generate more revenue for me.
Let's have a poll.
Who thinks I should set it?
Who thinks I'll get more revenue from a second price auction?
Who thinks I'll get more revenue from a first price auction.
Oh,
that's what this is the last poll of the class.
We can surely get no extensions.
Yeah,
let's try it again.
All right.
No extensions.
Last part of the class,
right?
Last fall,
the whole course.
Who thinks you get more?
I'm gonna expect more revenue from a second price auction in which people will
build,
bid their values,
but I only get the second price and who thinks I get more revenue from a first
price auction in which in which people pay?
They paid,
but they all stayed there.
Beds.
There's a slight majority of a second price.
Sorry.
Here's a fat.
A great therapy provided where in that setting I said pure private value.
Absolutely independent and my values completely just to be independent of your
value.
We're all basically similar,
independent,
private VAT,
symmetric,
private value,
both of those type of auctions we mentioned the first price auction and the
second price auction and indeed any other kind of auction which has the property
that in equilibrium,
the person with the highest value ends up winning the good.
Any stock auction in expectation yields exactly the same revenue and
expectation.
The first price auction,
the second price auction or any other silly old auction you come up with,
at least it has the property the next than in equilibrium.
The highest value wins.
All of them generate the same revenue in expectation.
But to find out why you're going to have to take another course in game three
cause we're done.
And I will see you at the review session
[inaudible].